et on va commencer Véronique avec une
invention assez écolo fini en effet les
gobelets en plastique un yvelinois
inventé quelque chose de très astucieux
des tasses à croquer et c'est quoi cette
très concrètement il est pas tout seul
il est avec son épouse Julie voilà ils
sont deux en voilà elle elle vient du
monde du cadeau elle a une boutique de
de d'idées cadeaux et lui a travaillé
longtemps dans l'événementiel donc il a
été à même de de constater le le nombre
de déchets que produisait n'importe quoi
un cocktail enfin une réception etc et
donc ils ont eu ensemble cette idée de
donc de s'associer pour ce projet qui a
du sens donc zéro déchet avec cette
tasse qui est constituée d'un biscuit
sec peu sucré je vois vos yeux vous êtes
en train de regarder oui c'est beau
avec une épaisse couche de chocolat noir
à 64% à l'intérieur et du coup ça sert
de contenant
de vous dire est-ce que ça fond pas du
coup avec le la boisson chaude ça ne
fond pas pourquoi parce que la
résistance est beaucoup plus faible avec
le la chaleur et le chocolat que entre
la porcelaine par exemple et je crois
que je suis en train de me dire
n'importe quoi bref ça ne fond pas parce
que ça soit dit vite voilà c'est bon
ça ne font pas et ça ne fuit pas non
plus bon en tout cas cette invention
100% est vinoise on pourra en parler et
puisqu'on va on va consacrer un
reportage sur sur cette invention donc
je pense que vous parlerez aussi des
recettes salées et du glaçage mystérieux
qui sont en train de mettre au point
pour que ça ne fuit pas pendant qu'on
puisse mettre des soupes même dedans
sucrés etc voilà c'est pour mars 23 les
autres recettes ça nous a donné en tout
cas on passe à un autre sujet alors qui
est assez inquiétant d'ailleurs mais qui
mérite toute notre attention c'est celui
de l'agribashing c'est quoi la
gribashing alors la coaching en fait
c'est un terme qui est apparu dans les
années 2016 et c'est une sorte de
mouvement de critique contre le mode de
production des agriculteurs intensifs
l'agriculture intensive voilà c'était
pour critiquer ça sauf que très vite ça
s'est étendu un peu à tout le monde
agricole en fait on a dénigré
systématiquement enfin certaines
personnes ont dénigré systématiquement
les agriculteurs et les résultats ils
sont ils sont probants ils sont là il y
a beaucoup de monde vaches dans les
campagnes les agriculteurs sont
découragés et sont pas sans pas
valoriser et donc voilà c'est ça vient
des des antispécistes à la base enfin
entre autres les antispécistes il faut
qu'ils ne veulent pas qui pour pour eux
l'espèce humaine et à égalité avec
l'espèce animale voilà
souvent d'actualité et notamment à
l'approche du salon de l'agriculture
d'ailleurs dernier exemple en date sur
l'agribashing ça se passe du côté de la
ville d'Adainville de la commune qui
se situe bien sûr dans les Yvelines ou
un agriculteur rencontre toute une série
de problèmes avec ses voisins
racontez-nous alors en fait oui c'est un
couple un jeune couple qui décide de
s'installer à Adainville donc charmant
petit village pour créer un élevage de
30 chevaux et de 15 vaches un élevage
bio 15 vaches de la race pin-noir qui
est une race de vache en voie
d'extinction une race bretonne voilà
donc tout va très bien sauf qu'en 2020
trois couples de leurs voisins se
mettent en tête de d'arrêter leurs
projets et imagine des nuisances et vont
donc en justice il y a un décret qui
leur donne raison mais ils vont de
recours en recours c'est plaignant donc
ça bloque le projet ça avait donc trois
ans et enfin la justice l'a rendu son
verdict donc ils ont tout à fait le
droit de de créer leur élevage et il
commence déjà à amener leurs animaux sur
place etc parce qu'ils ont dû être
hébergé après avant pardon chez d'autres
personnes et là on en reparle pourquoi
parce que malgré le fait que la justice
donc le parquet de Versailles leur est
donné complètement le droit de monter
leur élevage et bien c'est ses voisins
ont l'auront écrit une lettre anonyme
ici nos voisins et ce sont permis le
plus tranquillement du monde de rentrer
chez eux et de déposer la lettre anonyme
dans sur la table de la salle à manger
des agriculteurs
divulguée sur sur Twitter également
voilà faut savoir que le maire
d'Adainville ne défend complètement ses
jeunes agriculteurs et que faut pas
mettre tous les habitants du village
dans le même panier mais le problème de
de ce stagri machine c'est que ça
décourage et de moins en moins d'élevage
de petits élevages on va on manque de
vache en France on va devoir importer
des des bêtes de très loin donc le
circuit court la qualité la traçabilité
tout ça bah il va falloir oublier très
vite parce que on va continuer à
consommer de la viande elle viendra de
du Brésil par exemple ça met pas mal de
choses en question et forcément le sujet
je pense reviendra encore une fois sur
la table avec le son de l'A voitures qui
va s'ouvrir fin février à Paris merci
Véronique on vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine avec plaisir nouvelle idée
insolites